we have a down snow machine because the
storm advisory coming in the we're on a
timeframe here is not good for us we're
here red is all around us and the storm
is basically coming in so Norvik is
essentially right in the middle in the
eye of the storm as it will so we have
to get this thing fixed if we were to
ride without a without this thing
together this whole track kind of
collapses on itself something that you
don't really want to deal with out in
the field hopefully Joe our safety guide
could repair this thing and and we'll be
good to go here so all we can do is just
hope and pray and hopefully that nut and
that bolt fits and we can get on our way
okay all right there we are
that's that one's gonna work because I
think they're gonna be good so I'm just
gonna get this on here and it seems like
we got it fixed for the time being we're
gonna flip this thing back up right and
take a quick spin and see how it flows
but I think we're good to go
let's hear around negative 40 and so
linked cameras all day on snow machines
it's pretty gnarly today we are setting
traps with Andy and setting snares for
wolves for a trapping story but it's
basically around negative 40 to negative
35 right now so first thing we need to
do is like really layer up so I have
long underwear on now I have these
Carhartt
pretty and durable weather stuff some
some Gators to keep snow out of my boots
and pants but on top of that you have
these big down jackets it may look a
little excessive but it's pretty gnarly
up
you've been traveling for about an hour
and a half
haven't even started shooting for the
day yet they actually see wolf truck
right there and that's what we're here
about we're here to find Wolf's now we
can start shooting some TV
you